alright new video what should I play on
something different okay let's play
something entirely different let's go
from B 3 here right he played g6
i wonder if i can take on f6 slightly
risky now this move the idea is to clamp
down on d5 okay I was a good variety
would play d5 and now i can try to
establish some control here on diff can
you play a form no don't think so okay
and what now d 5 is nicely controlled I
think this III not G to set up might be
nice okay maybe you place a form alright
need to close the diagonal here that I
cannot leave for just just capture okay
my general address to play before be
five you can go 94 okay should try to at
least make it more difficult now before
coming up okay immediately before yeah
why not the general idea of this kind of
setup which is often seen in the [ __ ]
offski opening deform night after six
Bishop g5 is that this double porn
really makes blacks pawn structure
somewhat rigid and I want to open up the
diagonal here to get pressure on the
queenside okay here text the porn
it's d5 a good booth I don't think so i
don't want to blunt the bishop some
maybe i need to to cavity form and this
also shows that I maybe should have gone
to d3 anyway instead of c2 but ok it's
always a good thing to correct your
mistakes all right interesting c5 maybe
c5
yeah it shouldn't be too bad if he
captures b.tech CL have a nice target on
be 70 it does it he captures
surprisingly I mean I'm I've got already
made target on b7 now of course the
bishop is a bit blunted now but these
have nests also nice target but how to
continue just double I need to be
cautious about afar so you will play and
Bishop to see eight anyway let's get out
of the default first and back again with
the Queen okay but things have changed a
bit so to get out of this pin ok trying
to improve the pieces a bit ninety three
to five maybe but your cake in plain 97
I mean it's a nice position for white
but it's not so so obvious how to how to
improve and of course I'm down on time
hmm not quite sure how to play on here I
mean look looks nice for white but it's
not so evident how to proceed I want to
cover those sensitive square c 3 f 2 and
so on yeah but I have it covered III
yeah okay what's the draw
very difficult position yeah yeah time
was let them go to screen coming up here
yeah this is there should be two is of
course a risky move but I want to have
some counter play against be seven at
least yeah must have played this really
badly on the starter I think what was
was very fine not like winning and but
but it was it looked at look nice
there's a good structure so fairly solid
it's not like I'm losing or something
maybe I could have taken b7 maybe I
should be okay again really g5 was not
such a big deal trying to remove the
night now
28 seconds small for problem
I might sec the exchange now not to f5
this kind of a deal
yeah also just the idea rube rube to be
to also f5 is an idea to support the
night be five summers maybe an idea for
black here because I cannot take on plus
all because d6s hanging hmm what's
happening here you just let this clock
run down or some disconnect art I hope
I'm not disconnected but you it's hard
to tell sometimes yeah there's some
technical issue i guess but i cannot
really check now with 28 seconds maybe
briefly no my connection seems ok maybe
he just disconnected or something some
technical issue yeah it makes more sense
to spend so much time yeah shame and
what it was an interesting position
really and oops black4 fits on time this
was weird hmm
yeah II I got some some connection issue
yeah I'm not quite sure the position
looks looks highly unclear to me and I'm
I'll turn on the computer briefly it
gives it a sequel 000 funny enough yeah
yeah but it's well it's it's unclear for
a human at least 000 as always sounds
like that's the first draw something
computer gives them 26 here so here
Queenie 6 and then we move like a 4
which makes sense to prevent this beam
bb5 idea then look C to B 2 and B 7s a
problem but yeah and black has got
counter play with the H porn yeah
computer cords that even no idea a black
shouldn't have any problems White's King
has some always some constant very here
and if you wouldn't have this
disconnection I think I would have have
huge trouble with the time was 28
seconds against close to two minutes oh
alright thanks for watching